does that make you 12.
don't rank us 11.
take that talk back man
ohio state players ohio state players
very excited rightfully so
uh they took on clemson no i'll get
there oh don't you
don't don't you there don't you dare
i'll get there i'm just setting the
context
i'm just going to help us frame the
conversation just let people know what
they saw and what they heard
ohio state is very excited what uh-huh
oh yeah very excited after a sugar bowl
win
over clemson ohio state uh
was the number three team in the
playoffs clemson was number two
they played last year they lost by six
points to clemson 29-23 they went up
16-0
and then trevor lawrence and clemson
came back to beat them
and that was one of the things that ohio
state football talked about the entire
offseason
they wanted to avenge that defeat to
clemson they felt like they were the
best team in the country
and they they let that game get away um
now where i come in mike is
i've had a little complicated
relationship with ohio state lately you
know i grew up there
buckeye through and through but one
i didn't think they should have been
playing football this year two after six
games
six games not enough to qualify
for the playoffs to be taken okay good
seriously
i'm glad you all pay off threats
because you know my memory you know my
memory is pretty bad for somebody else
it is bad and i and i was like wait
didn't you co-sign
dabble then didn't you see where he was
i did coach sound say
he's different yeah you here's the
difference
i don't have the best coach against him
i don't have to coach him get the devil
hey mike come on bro
don't don't put it like this put it to
you like this
you can't put
your foot in your mouth
and get somebody else's foot put in your
behind
like why don't we go you can't do both
like if you're gonna put your foot in
your mouth
they can't put their foot in your ass i
mean it was like i mean
at least what is this uh was it aj
johnson from friday
did you at least pinch him like right
at least it was a close game and and so
it really what it shows you
is like you know double down after the
game do you hear him after the game
right which is
typical dabble typical dabble okay like
no i don't have any resistance no you
should keep that keep that quiet keep
that private
that's just one of those things where
you say it look
uh i had this i had a formula
and now i i think about my for my
formula is wrong
he didn't have a form i shouldn't you
know i shouldn't use
he didn't have a formula and that's the
problem michael this is why this is why
dabo shouldn't live this down i know
they've been in four championships in
five years and
i believe one two of them or something
like that i mean he's one of the best
coaches in america okay
uh but dabo gets out of pocket quite a
bit
for my liking on a number of levels on a
number of subjects especially when he's
the latest when he's told
he on football he's usually pretty good
when he goes away
when he goes away from the field oh
now remember what we talked about
earlier unscripted
uh how great aaron rodgers and patrick
mahomes are unscratched
dabo unscripted it's a disaster he's
thinking
dancer just stick to dancing you know
just dance in the locker room
do your thing but it's like which is why
yes i did not have a dog in this fight
the way you did
but nonetheless i did find some joy
in dabo getting his comeuppance and i
don't think he should let this down
anytime soon
because he didn't his his coach's poll
he used it as his commentary
versus actually saying because i don't
even think he watched ohio state this
year
is that you know he could act in terms
of actually trying to evaluate them and
i don't know how much thought most
coaches put in coach like
but it looks like he didn't watch him he
coached like he wasn't familiar with
their work but it's clear
that he did not rank them according
because it's not like ohio state said
you know what we're gonna do this year
we're gonna play six games it's like nah
man like everybody's been dealing with a
pandemic
they didn't initially cancel the big ten
season themselves we all know how that
played out they didn't cancel the games
along the way
just because dabble doesn't care about
kovitt doesn't mean that everybody else
in the country wasn't affected by it
so remember he went inside he went out
on florida state as
if yeah yeah that's another example the
virus so you know right there
for him to decide that a team that like
you pointed out
he saw him last year knows how how good
this program is one of the best programs
in the country
for him to have the audacity to rank
them 11th
i in the first place i'm not surprised
that he doubled down
because that's what dabo does because he
he was out of his mind in the first
place when he ranked him 11. and so no
he's not going to take it back because
he was about the wrong thing he didn't
actually think they were the 11th
best team in the country he just wanted
to make a point that somehow he needed
to see him for four more games to
believe that they belonged in the
playoffs what does it matter okay
six games or two that's not what is that
that's kind of crazy
i don't know i don't know if that's a
crazy i always thought it was a flawed
argument
that's not that crazy um because
you you can you play you can be upset so
you play
yeah the more the more you play michael
the more you play
the more likely you are to lose a game i
get that but it doesn't mean that you're
somehow worse than a team
who went 9-0 because you only went six
in them
okay now that's where that's where i
i'll lose it because you can be upset
just because you get upset doesn't mean
that you're suddenly a bad team
they're not the 11th best team in the
country that's just ridiculous
so nobody nobody really believes we know
that now the only well we knew that
before the game
the only issue with is do you believe
that a team
i'm gonna get to this in a second
because this is what really bothers me
this is why i'm back on the bandwagon i
was off the bandwagon i'll admit it i
ain't letting you back on
i ain't letting you back okay i'm
getting back home
i'm i'm i'm you you're when you it's my
birthday you have to stand
you're gonna have to stand okay i'll
stand i'm standing i hold
it's it's not only my birth right it's
my birth it's my birth right
okay to be back on the ohio state
bandwagon
uh but this is this is why i'm back on
mike
because of what i will hear and what you
will hear
leading up to monday and i just pray
that we don't have to deal with this on
tuesday
i know there's an east coast bias in a
lot of things and most things
hip-hop east coast bias sports coverage
east coast bias yeah yeah
but there's a southeastern conference
bias
that drives me crazy so when ohio state
plays alabama on monday
a week from tonight they're not just
you're not just representing the state
of ohio
you're just now representing the big ten
you're representing
every non-sec school out there
because they act like they invented
football
they act like they invented speed like
nobody else is fast
it's only like sec teams and so you know
what i hey
you know what i found them yeah you know
what the door was that's third ten
people
they act like their third or fourth best
oh yeah oh yeah it's an inferiority
complex
it's like a little bit of a serious
complex it's a blind spot
whatever it is it's that it's that the
sec
somehow somebody's more arrogant when it
comes to football than you are
that's what bothers me 10 people it's
like wait a minute
we're supposed to be acting like that
we're the cradle of football
where's somebody where are you no but
the big ten never acted like that
the big ten never acted like that like
the sec does
sec acts like it's a whole new level
it's not just the secrets
it's that people buy into it media buy
into it that's what they say
oh you know what yeah you finished fifth
in the sec
but that means you can win any other uh
conference
in the country i know that's the worst
and so they're surprised
like they're surprised i i guarantee you
alabama
is shocked that ohio state beat them six
years ago
2015 beat them what how'd they beat us
this little team ohio what are they
doing
they don't play in the sec and so they
must they ain't got to win they ain't
got to blow them out
beat him by a point beat him by seven
beat him by 20. i don't care just win
because i cannot stand
the chatter and it's not just alabama
it's from everybody in the sec like ole
miss be talking trash
they were like 500. they gonna be
talking
mississippi state's terrible they're
gonna be talking
you know i don't want to hear hecarim
you're lucky you for bad what
i'm gonna give you a pass i'm gonna give
you a pass i'm giving out the passes
why no it's okay you know it's fine you
know because you were
so frankly rude
when i tried to get you hyped about the
season you told me
about watching ohio state foreign i have
never
listen man i've had some bad moments on
television before
i have never bombed like that i have
never misread
the field in my entire career i
have what i've had some moments but my
point is i was like wait
he's akron ohio state's own buckeye o-h
he's gonna love this you were like yeah
hey i'm not watching
you saw me you told me you weren't
watching a single game this year you
told me you were not
watching a game so i was coming here
okay in scarlet and gray right now it's
like so i guess
i guess it doesn't matter we're still in
this pandemic you're good now you're
good with them playing right now
the champions but listen we're all we're
all figuring that how about this
here's a cliche you know mike yeah um
during this difficult time
we're all figuring out in this new
normal
we're all trying to find our way i give
you the cliche all day long i hope this
message i hope this message finds you
well
during this challenging time hey thanks
for watching brother from another on
youtube make sure you hit subscribe
before you leave and be sure to watch us
3-5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you